Bravo's ghost words executive
vice-president Madigan faculty
colleagues alumni doctoral candidates
and their families and friends good
evening and welcome to convocation for
doctoral candidates in the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences I thank all
of you for coming to celebrate the
accomplishments of our PhD candidates we
honor today a magnificent group that on
commencement is coming Wednesday will
join the ranks of our over 40,000 alumni
and who will embark on professional and
academic careers around the world in the
great tradition of Columbia University
equally important we also honor today
the families and friends of our
candidates who have endured with them
the grueling marathon of the doctoral
degree thank you for being so supportive
and above all for being so very patient
a special recognition is due today to
the mothers in the audience who I'm sure
have wondered more than once whether
this day would finally arrive I would
ask all doctoral candidates to write and
applaud those friends and family members
who have helped them to be here today
[Applause]
the student remarks to the graduating
class will be offered by misny I you as
you received her BA from Cambridge
University and is a PhD student in the
Department of Political Science her
dissertation work brings together
neuroscience and political science
focusing especially on dehumanization
and identity politics with a larger
purpose of asking what cognitive
conditions are necessary for us to
coexist in today's hyper diverse
societies a German citizen was
originally born in Hunan China Lea
applies a research work to projects on
immigrants mental health and
anticipating prejudice between people
from the west and the east her literary
works has won awards in Germany and she
continues to search for a new language
through both politics and literature to
help intercultural people to achieve
their humanity in four myth you
[Applause]
[Music]
Dean Alonzo Provost cotesworth executive
vice president American faculty and
hardworking staff dear families and
friends but most important do PhD class
of 2017 I feel extremely honored today
to deliver the student speech and would
like to start by thanking my true
advisers in the political science
department David Johnston and Jack
Snyder as well as LaDonna Harris from
UCL my other committee members Robert
Jervis and Helen Vidal II from Teachers
College as well as my parents husband
three-year-old son and friends who are
sitting in the audience today I am here
today to talk about what Columbia means
to me as a place as an enigmatic place
of arrival and possibility a place that
marks my intellectual biography a
tangible place in which a multitude of
my identities for the space to speak to
each other on one of my first lush
summer evenings on campus seven years
ago when I was sitting with a newly made
friend on the steps of Lowe library we
were watching how the lights of butter
library just behind you opposite of us
then were beginning to peel sprightly
into the soft darkening sky one small
window after the other my friend and I
talked about how for our hypermobile
generation places and locations are
often piled onto each other without
clear order whereas recounting specific
years provides more structure and
clarity for this generation the memories
of places that we travel to and from and
that relieves behind an immerse
ourselves in can quickly become a
jumbled and the wildering collection of
instead specific years begin to
structures almost as if they light up in
front of our eyes like the role of
bright windows of Butler library into
the darkness of the sky yet today I want
to make the case that our memory of
Columbia is especially precious for a
hyper mobile generation like ours
because it is deeply etched into us as a
memory and experience of place above all
I came to Columbia from having studied
political philosophy in the UK I grew up
in Germany I was born in China and has
arrived at Columbia with many question
marks about my intellectual and cultural
belonging I wrote an interdisciplinary
dissertation that employs the social
neuroscience on prejudice stereotyping
and dehumanization of others to build a
Naropa litical theory of how we can live
together cooperatively in hyper diverse
and divided societies Columbia's campus
sits winded corridors and the pre-war
building the seminar rooms the libraries
and above all its people became a
physically tangible and contained place
where I could draw connections between
my conflicting identities academically
it became a place where my quest to
create a new neural political language
and interdisciplinary theory for today's
identity politics
I could literally cross disciplinary
boundaries by walking over to the
offices and seminar rooms of different
departments and libraries on Morningside
campus within a matter of hours within a
whole long day as I was contemplating
during my graduate years what impact the
brain has on politics and how politics
reflects in the brain I could cross
campus and connected the disparate
intellectual fields in my mind
neuroscience and political philosophy by
walking across campus space
but just like any physical place that is
able to grip our imagination Columbia is
a place that once attracts our most
daring visions and yet most vulnerable
longings if like me you have ever
wondered and despaired about who you are
how are you supposed to think and how
you are supposed to talk about yourself
in light of the often conflicting
cultural racial linguistic and gender
identities that you carry within you
then you will know that works such as
belonging home and liberation are not
just abstract concepts but powerful and
enticing sounds that compel you to
explore them with an almost irrational
yearning and resolution when I arrived
at Columbia I wanted to understand the
force of social identity such as race
culture and class in determining
political outcomes in a post-cold war
world order I was motivated by my
upbringing by Chinese parents in
post-war unified Germany I was puzzled
how identity politics could lead to such
disastrous outcomes such as the
Holocaust and the Cultural Revolution
but at the same time how it could also
lead to empowering triumphs such as the
civil rights movement and desegregation
in the US as well as the feminist
movement and post-colonial liberation
why did identity politics in the 20th
century lead to such disastrous and yet
triumphant outcomes and how are we to
learn from this for the identity
politics of the 21st century in our
increasingly hyper diverse and divided
societies mmm but of course it is so
often the case the deepest and most
hidden but also most desperate and
powerful drives behind my questions came
from my own self they came from my own
experience as an intercultural minority
woman who did not know whether she
belong to the east or west for my
experience of being rejected as
Western Buffalo Chinese and as to
foreign by fellow Western professors
colleagues and friends for my experience
of not knowing which history was truly
writing me and which history I should
help writing from yearning for place
that I could call my intellectual home
where I belong without being put into
said identity categories where I could
ask questions and try to answer them in
a crispness and unfairness that allowed
me to focus completely on a question
itself a place where the beginning of
each day was not marked by that stinging
sense of shame that still too many of us
who moved from identity margins into the
center allowed to wash over ourselves I
was looking for a place where did not
matter so much who you once were but
what you said thought and responded to
in this very moment in a seminal room a
research lab and a lecture hall took on
importance and above all reality
Columbia the campus in New York as a
city became that place where the words
belonging home and liberation could be
uttered completely anew however I'm not
trying to idolize Columbia here today
either my memory of Columbia's also
marked by contestation of its place by
who is represented and allowed entry
here I'm sitting back of my time as a
student senator when when I engaged in
heated debates about Columbia's global
identity without ECS return to campus
our Columbia's responsibility to invest
ethically low-income students who
confessed about their struggles with
food stems and finances black lives
matter demonstrations as well as the
story direction of a plaque that honors
fill a nappy people in 2016 therefore
when I think back my time yet Columbia's
marked both by the liberation that the
space offers to intercultural people
like me
but also by the constant awareness that
this space needs to be continuously
contested reclaimed and transformed by a
diverse assembly of voices the meaning
of the place also comes from seeing it
with somebody else's eyes I would not be
the person I am today and I'm sure you
would agree without the undergraduate
students that I have taught to consider
the identity challenges of our time
through the perspective of this youngest
generation on campus has been deeply
humbling for me giving me true joy and
purpose likewise our parents and family
who are sharing the special moments with
us today
carry within them the knowledge of other
continents histories and political
errors which is why seeing us on stage
today in this place in this city at this
moment is deeply touching and moving to
us but perhaps even more so to them dear
class of 2017 I leave you with this
image of Butler library's lights
lighting up like the years that are to
unfold unfold before after our
graduation but also with a visceral
sense of place connected to Columbia of
that period in your life where the
fractured identity perhaps within you
for enlightenment and meaning and a true
sense of belonging in a single Haven of
time and place thank you very much
thank you me to you the keynote address
will be offered by Alondra Nelson
professor of sociology and Dean of
social science at Columbia University
Dean Nelson has published broadly on the
intersections of science technology and
social inequality her acclaimed books
include the social life of DNA rates
reparations and reconciliation after the
genome and body and soul the Black
Panther Party and the fight against
medical discrimination on September 1st
she will become president of the social
science research council and she's also
the chair elect of the science knowledge
and Technology section of the American
Sociological Association the Nelson is a
magna laude graduate of the
University of California at San Diego
and earned her MPhil and PhD in American
Studies from New York University Dean
Nelson
Dean Alonzo Provost coats cotesworth
executive vice president Madigan
colleagues and most importantly to the
doctoral candidates we gather to
celebrate this evening and your families
and friends it is my honor and pleasure
to have been asked to address you on
this important occasion graduation
season has always been one of my
favorite times of year like the start of
each new academic semester graduation
brings with it the promise of the
journey that lies ahead but better than
the start of a new term graduation marks
the accumulation of many new semesters
the successful completion of many
academic terms graduation season marks a
significant achievement accomplished
over an extended period of time
and sometimes despite great odds in the
case of the doctoral degree the highest
academic degree that one can attain that
you candidates start to receive today we
are also acknowledging a lifetime of
dedication and pursuit of this goal for
as long as I can remember my celebration
of graduation season has included an
annual ritual of selecting just the
right book to give as a gift to the
Graduate sometimes I gifted books that
were linked to a friend or family
members postgraduate aspirations on
other occasions the books I selected
carried forward a discussion that had
taken place in the classroom and that I
hope the Graduate and I would continue
well into the future but for the last
decade or so I have selected only one
book just one book as a graduation gift
ethical ambition by the legal scholar
Derrick Bell published in 2002 nine
years before his passing at the age of
80 in years past I meld books to
Professor Bell and he'd write a personal
note to each graduate in recent years
I've written notes of my own to the
graduates to whom I'd give his book
ethical ambition is now available in a
second edition with a charming cover
image of Professor bill standing in the
foreground and front of what appears to
be a chalkboard but I still much prefer
the original cover of this book so much
so that I continue to scour youth
bookstores for it so I can give this
preferred one as the gift I prefer this
first one because it is an unadorned
cover the words ethical ambition in
greyscale lettering are set against a
silver black drop backdrop that lends
the work a tone that is both declarative
and imperative I prefer this cover
because it plainly states ethical
ambition as a quiet mandate a tender
prodding rather than a mere suggestion a
suggestion on the part of the author
I've given this book as a gift again and
again because it distills
into prose some of the guidance that I
had the benefit of receiving from
professor Bell as a graduate student and
a junior professor he was one of my most
impactful mentors by the time of my
first encounter with him in the late
1990s I had already read several of his
books but I knew a professor Bell long
before this he was the faculty member
who took an unpaid leave of absence from
Harvard Harvard Law School where he was
the first african-american tenured
professor and refused to intern return
until the institution had hired a black
woman faculty member in effect giving up
his tenure at the institution this is
not a fate I wanted for myself or I hope
for you but in addition to being in awe
of his professional courage I admired
his contrarian scholarship and his life
of conviction his writing was erudite
yet accessible and even literary and it
asked as always to take an unflinching
honest look at our still too uneven
society I met professor Bell at a
reception one of these set receptions
that you graduate students will recall
following an academic event it was one
of those informal but never ever casual
gatherings at which we aspirant PhDs
find ourselves with the opportunity to
deliver our dissertation elevator
pitches too long credentialed eminent
faculty members
I know these encounters are one part of
your graduate education that you won't
miss filter brimming with emotional
intelligence for vesser Bell appreciated
how unnerving this experience was and
listened patiently and even
appreciatively as the graduate students
arrayed around him rattled off our spiel
to him he had priest prays for each of
us and reminded us that we as scholars
with our variant varied projects all had
the potential to change the world before
this moment no one had encouraged me to
even entertain the fact that this might
be possible or true he held ambitions
for we students that we could not yet
hold for ourselves
I've also gifted professor Bell's book
ethical ambition again and again because
it boldly places front and center a
question we are not often encouraged to
think often enough about how can I
maintain my integrity while seeking
success
well responded to this question in this
book with a series of poignant essays
about passion courage faith
relationships
ethics and humility and the arc of one's
ethical professional life and ethical
ambition the all-too-human Bell is
deeply honest with his readers admitting
that he was not adverse to pursuing
success and indeed that he was a very
ambitious man
he also encouraged us as Courage's us
that in our lifetimes we can in his
words do well and do good he encourages
us that our abilities and talents can be
used towards professional success and to
transform the world for the better
I don't consider ethical ambition an
oxymoron Bell writes ethical conduct
connotes activity that is fair uplifting
and in keeping with and one hopes
advancing moral norms and ambition is
not merely a desire for wealth positions
power or celebrity but rather in his
word
an earnest desire for some
accomplishment or distinction and the
willingness to strive for it you
doctoral candidates seated here today
already embody the second more profound
sense of ambition you have over several
years strive toward the goal that we
honor you for today to put your
accomplishments in some perspective I
will remind you that recent US census
data on educational attainment tells us
that fewer than 2% of people in the US
have earned a doctoral degree so this
experience that seems commonplace and
ubiquitous to many of you and to many of
us by the time we complete graduate
school having spent many years
surrounded by others who hold dr. --ax
to achieving this highest degree is
actually a rare and unique feat there's
no two ways about it you are exceptional
doing well and doing good as Bell
advised is surely a hard balance to
strike but if anyone is capable of this
it is you the distinguished members of
the doctoral class of 2017 for your
presence here today means that you have
mastered not only your disciplines and
fields of study but also the task that
is demanded uniquely of doctoral
candidates looking at the world anew and
drawing new possibilities new
discoveries new interpretations and
bringing forward the original and
innovative contributions for which you
are being honored if a balance between
ethics and ambition is to be struck it
will take novel perspective on success
and the common good and few are better
prepared to chart this new way than
those of you here today and your years
at Columbia you've had the amazing
opportunity and privilege to be able to
focus on one aspect of knowledge over an
extended period of time through years of
dedicated and painstaking work you have
learned what it takes to really know
something going through this experience
has shown you the value of deep study
and has assured you of your ability to
tackle complexity and intricate
see even when it's hard what's your
doctoral training has shown you to do is
think deeply and with nuance about the
complexities of life be they metaphors
or jain methylation or machine learning
whatever else happens in your life you
are transformed forever by having taking
this journey and having successfully
done so at a place like columbia what
you've accomplished has taken great
skill and great discipline there's no
two ways about it you are extraordinary
there will be many exciting ways for you
to take your experiences out into the
world and to take your expertise out
into the world the collective you will
propel forward into careers that
variously advance human understanding
doing any of this is a mighty plenty
doing any of this is doing well but what
about striking this balance between
doing well and doing good and why does
this matter it matters because we face
many challenges from health care access
to climate change to enhancing social
justice to ensuring democracy and these
times when it may seem easier to take
solace and oversimplified answers to any
of these the skills and nuanced thinking
that you have honed over many years are
key and are deeply in need wherever you
will land know that the world needs
people like you who can think deeply
about the world around them before me
this evening are a group of the world's
greatest minds and this is beautiful to
behold having learned to inhabit the
life of the mind I want to urge you to
remember not to live only guided by the
minds but also by the heart at the coal
ambitions seeks to use the rare
knowledge acquired over many years of
intellectual innovation and some way
towards human betterment ethical
ambition is doing work that dedicates
you to a better world and indeed that
dedicates you to use the very same
skills of innovation that you've
developed that have brought Columbia and
have brought you here today to imagine a
better world during your doctoral
studies you will have fail
old stealth unsettled and even
uncomfortable when you took risks
ethical ambition ask that you continue
to live lives of this kind of courage
guiding us to not just see new
algorithms and formulae not only new
theories and theorems not only new
compositions or curricula but to put
this radical thinking that you are
expert at in the service of us all
ethical ambition is surely a more rocky
path and ambition alone but it is the
path that can bring together the roads
of intellectual satisfaction and
personal fulfillment and it is that path
that brings the intellectual creativity
and originality for which you are being
honored to bear on some of our most
seemingly intractable issues ethical
ambition is an ambition for others as
well as oneself an appreciation that we
each have unique skills that can Yoon Li
uniquely offer something to the world
and whatever your sphere of influence or
expertise do something for the good of
others imagine if you will a future of
work your future catalyzed by the
convictions of the heart as well as the
passions of the mind take this
passionate intelligence the fullness of
what you have learned as students at
Columbia out into the world and make our
world anew congratulations to the class
of 2017 on this wonderful day when we
are gathered together to celebrate your
academic success it is my hope you will
soar to the heights of your imagining
and do so while also drawing on your
deep well of knowledge to be a service
to others and to the world
Thank You Dean Nelson I now have the
pleasure of introducing Miss Sarah
Joseph a PhD student in genetics and
development and the president of the
Graduate Student Advisory Council who
will present the faculty mentoring
awards miss Joseph today I had the
distinct privilege of representing all
GSA F students and recognizing two
outstanding professors the Graduate
Student Advisory Council confers the
faculty mentoring award to honor
excellence in the mentoring of PhD
students these faculty members have
demonstrated an exceptional commitment
to supporting their students and guiding
them along a path of educational and
professional development selections for
the faculty mentoring award were made by
graduate student representatives from
GAF and other columbia schools from a
set of nomination letters spanning all
disciplines
today we honor oded Netzer associate
professor of Business and Van C Tran
assistant professor of sociology
professor van tranh the selection
committee was very impressed by the
nomination letters received on your
behalf
a few relevant passages from your
nomination letters are accepted below
professor van tranh is an amazing model
of a sociologist mentor and teacher that
I want to become he expertly led class
discussions and elicited thoughts and
opinions from everyone in the room in a
way that allowed people to feel that
their contributions were respected and
important to the discussion professor
van trans guidance played a key role in
the development of my successful
proposal his holistic mentoring goes
beyond being an excellent academic
advisor on behalf of all of the graduate
students at Columbia University we thank
you for your outstanding mentorship
effective mentoring not only the key to
a successful graduate program but also
establishes a legacy of quality
mentoring practices for your students we
are honored to recognize your
achievements in the signature element of
graduate education
[Applause]
the selection committee was very
impressed by the nomination letters
received on professor nesters behalf a
few relevant passages from your
nomination letters are accepted below as
a mentor Oda challenges his students to
refine and perfect their ideas providing
invaluable insights and training along
the way he is always available to guide
help and provide feedback his mentoring
style is supportive and destructive yet
encouraging one to push forward and
reach the best results while not
neglecting the learning process
Odin is truly the ideal mentor and
friend and Colombia's enormous lucky to
count him as a member of its community
on behalf of all the graduate students
at Columbia University we thank you for
your outstanding mentorship effective
mentoring not only is the key to a
successful graduate program but also
establishes a legacy of quality
mentoring practices for your students we
are honored to recognize your
achievements in the signature element of
graduate education professor nectars
unable to attend today's ceremony
cheeri mill ahmad a PhD kannan business
is here to accept the award on professor
nesters behalf
[Applause]
thank you miss Joseph and
congratulations to professor's Netzer
and Trent we will now recognize three
PhD students with the Presidential Award
for outstanding teaching these students
were selected from a large pool of
nominations by a committee that included
both faculty and graduate students
Provost goes forth
would you please come forward the three
students who have been selected to
receive this year's Presidential Award
for outstanding teaching are sahar HT
Akula Jason junior wong and shing woo
woo
[Applause]
missoula like all top graduate student
teachers you regularly win the praises
of your students not only do many refer
to you as the best teaching assistant
they have ever had but they describe you
as one of the most impressive
instructors of any rank they have
encountered at Columbia in the classroom
you model the modes of questioning and
interacting that you wish to instill in
your students you demonstrate the
balance between allowing students to
develop their own ideas and challenging
them when appropriate as much of your
teaching involves the basic intellectual
introduction of students to the study of
Arabic and Islamic cultures you have
also mastered the skills required to
help students transform their
assumptions into culturally competent
evidence-based lenses through which they
analyze these subjects beyond the
classroom you act as a mentor to your
peers and model the commitment required
of the profession of teaching the
standards you set for yourself bring out
the best in your colleagues students and
classmates it is with great respect
gratitude and pride that we recognize
your contributions and accomplishments
in the classroom and Beyond with a 2017
Presidential Award for outstanding
teaching by a graduate student
[Applause]
mr. Wong through your teaching you
demonstrate deep passion for your
subject that highlights your unique
ability to deliver complex and abstract
materials into simple easily consumable
information your enthusiasm expertise
and love for learning is translated
through your teaching allowing students
to make real connections between the
subject matter world events and their
everyday life as a teacher you're
patient understanding and compassionate
person and your door seems to be open to
students always not just for assisting
with coursework but also for mentorship
and counsel your teaching is creative
and innovative and your use of multiple
pedagogical methods goes far beyond the
basic lecture we're proud to have you as
both a student and teacher at the School
of International and public affairs and
it is with great respect and gratitude
that we recognize your contributions and
accomplishments in the classroom and
beyond with the 2017 presidential Award
for outstanding teaching by a graduate
student
[Applause]
and finally mr. Wu as a teacher your
expertise and ability to explain
complicated concepts in simple terms has
revealed to many students the beauty of
mathematics associated with economics
and has sparked their curiosity in new
pursuits of knowledge your kindness and
patience contribute to a warm and
inviting classroom and your generosity
has made a long-lasting impression on
both your students and your colleagues
we were the first point of contact for
students in the inaugural Masters of
Arts in economics and you expertly
guided them as an instructor teaching
assistants friends and mentor your
efforts were instrumental to the success
of the program in its first year both
undergraduate and doctoral students
alike have learned so much from you even
when no longer formally assigned to your
classes it is with great respect
gratitude and pride that we recognize
your contributions and your
accomplishments in the classroom and
beyond with the 2017 presidential Award
for outstanding teaching by a graduate
student
we now arrive at the central point of
the ceremony the presentation of the
doctoral candidates we ask you to come
forth as we call your name in
recognition of your individual
accomplishments there is berge assistant
dean of students for the Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences will read the names
of the PhD candidates as they approach
the lectern
receiving a doctoral degree in
anthropology
sumaya Casa Molly RT Sethi su Yong Kim
Natasha
sabi mana Christopher Santiago Jude
Machoke woo
receiving the doctoral degree in Applied
Physics Andrew Wiseman - Lee Chaitanya
Rastogi
Kenneth Hammond Alexander Watson
[Applause]
Jonathan Mordecai Kornbluth dog Rhodes
diego scarab le gents Bartel receiving a
doctoral degree in art history and
archaeology Kevin do Michelle nicole
Griggs to her son Pelosi
Eliza Butler Rachael silvery receiving
the doctoral degree in astronomy
Stephanie Douglas giu Susan Clark
receiving the doctoral degree in
biochemistry and molecular biophysics
Brett Alcott Bridget flung Jane Martin
Carley receiving the doctoral degree in
biological sciences Nicole Ben Ben
Jaime little soy in Park Chiu Fung Amy
job J Joe Ming's son Nathan your Co
receiving the doctoral degree in
biomedical engineering
Genevieve Brown
[Music]
Ethan bunting Edward Vogel the third
Brendon Roche Robert John NIMS Jonathan
Ungh way engine Nollan Katie be wound
syrup on jar Rancic Wu Shi Jing Yan
hyung Yin ma receiving a doctoral degree
in biomedical informatics Albert Lee Jin
hey Silas Chung William oh gollu
receiving the doctoral degree in
biostatistics zu wrong huang receiving
the doctoral degree in business Ethan
Ruan shin Lee Lee Elizabeth Wylie
Ilona Friedman GRU Daniel her shurima
Lumad dong-wook shin when she who
kaiyuan jelly Andreea Chigwell Pablo
Slutsky
receiving a doctoral degree in cell
biology
Chinchin you receiving a doctoral degree
in cellular physiology and biophysics
you-jin you tall Lorber bomb
Nicole Steinbach Deepti masseur
receiving a doctoral degree in cellular
molecular and biomedical studies Boris
Greenspun yaw Jing Jie
raging drew June cui Jian Joseph pilla
Hren
Alexandra Hudson ski George moon moon to
Ferris Chandler Walker
[Music]
Wendy Fong receiving the doctoral degree
in chemical engineering Haruna's bakr
[Applause]
har took beta lulu Tolo Mayank Mitra
Kibo Sophie receiving the doctoral
degree in chemical engineering Maksim
stoner kevin nur
[Applause]
poor accrete leo para tratar Unger de
Silva use whoa fusion Jung receiving the
doctoral degree in chemical physics
giselle Elbaz receiving the doctoral
degree in chemistry
Travis Valadez join you
elation for now who Nathaniel Kim
Stewart Mallory Michael - learn carry
Yas wek Miguel he Menace receiving a
doctoral degree in civil engineering and
engineering mechanics Maurer Torres
Audrey Olivier David tall
Matthew Sloan Nandan Shetty
Mustafa MOBA sure
Jin woo Yong Yong Chun Wang receiving
the doctoral degree in classical studies
Molly Allen receiving the doctoral
degree in computer science
Heba l4d Daniel Bauer Robert Cohen
[Applause]
Sebastian Simic Paulo Mantovani Jung Jin
Eun ji Wei Fung of near may chill
Jermaine receiving a doctoral degree in
earth and environmental sciences hey one
Kim Julius kiseki Logan Brenner
[Applause]
Sofia premier osmea p2 Angelika
Patterson Abigail West receiving the
doctoral degree in East Asian languages
and cultures
Glenda Chao
jae-hwan Chang Feng you receiving the
doctoral degree in ecology evolution an
environmentally ology Camilla sannin
[Music]
Brian week's case Prager
Naomi Schwartz receiving the doctoral
degree in economics Mae ping son Stefan
de Pras Asian Lee yogi Deshawn Dasani
he'll become a GRE gran mother s ki am
boost Yvonne Lena Liu daily her kerim -
Shalu Maryam Michaelis piache
Christopher Hanson Nicholas Tarrou
Zachary Brown Evan real tech young Tom
receiving the doctoral degree in
electrical engineering Sala Sultan
Varun Gupta
David Calhoun Christine Chen k1 Scott
Rokia receiving a doctoral degree in
electrical engineering
Hyungsik Kim Jon abhi Sharma sure will
predict Patil you Jen Junction jus
Ritesh spot
Lin Xiao Zhang Christopher Troy you gon
jus son receiving the docile degree in
English and comparative literature
Kathleen Gemmell art and higly receiving
a doctoral degree in Environmental
Health Sciences Modena Jackson Browne
receiving the doctoral degree in
epidemiology Melissa DuPont reyes Linda
gross Khan Stephanie Xiao Sheila Anna
met Xiao Jing she receiving the doctoral
degree in French and romance philology
Elizabeth's Jacqueline Marcos Diana King
Johan right Burt receiving the doctoral
degree in genetics and development oh
yeah Yara Sofia
Cassandra paella Lori creamy on
receiving the doctoral degree in
Germanic languages Sophie salvo to be a
vice Honus vor Jessica cursing receiving
the doctoral degree in history Sarah run
see Maria John O'Reilly Roy Jude Webber
[Applause]
Romeo Guzman honor Isabel keelson
Justin Reynolds Justin Reynolds
[Applause]
Benjamin Lyons Deborah Shula vez Jeffrey
way no Deborah Gail Joseph Skloot
Nicholas sure of it jin-yi
ian shin Carolyn arena
[Music]
Samuel Fury child's daily Nishant bachi
ciao Charles Halverson receiving a
doctoral degree in industrial
engineering and operations research
etai bacon bomb Gonzalo muoz aunt Wanda
fear
[Applause]
Mariana Fraga
[Music]
[Applause]
Jennifer roads Peter van Hove receiving
the doctoral degree in Latin American
and Iberian cultures at least Arnold
Levine Rachel Stein Donna Mendes Oliver
receiving a doctoral degree in
mathematics
young soo choy Ashwin do pork air jordan
Keller Paul Lewis
Vladislav Petkov shinmin Mike Wong
receiving the doctoral degree in
mechanical engineering
Paul steagle grant Randall
shook we muffin who Frank y'all show
young chef received the doctoral degree
in earth and environmental engineering
sadly receiving a doctoral degree in
microbiology and immunology yin watchin
Melanie mu mal receiving a doctoral
degree in middle eastern South Asian and
African Studies - heart
Lula Ahmed dear dear Janet Marshall
receiving the doctoral degree in music
Nicholas strong re he'll oh it's Matthew
rickets
Benjamin Hansberry mace turbines
receiving a doctoral degree in
neurobiology and behavior you're a fox
[Applause]
yo chef may saw us
Austin citko Gamal Eldin Elsayed Chris
off to pray receiving the doctoral
degree in nutritional and metabolic
biology Elizabeth millings receiving a
doctoral degree in pathobiology and
molecular medicine
Michael Badgley jennifer crow receiving
the doctoral degree in pharmacology and
molecular signaling
sethro be lujon song Jung Chang Chau
receiving the doctoral degree in
philosophy matthew moss christine suzy
Enka receiving the doctoral degree in
physics
Mickey McDonald David calico Derrick
Aroo Joe Andre Petri
[Applause]
sky Chun Yong Yong Russell Smith David
Murphy receiving a doctoral degree in
political science Hiroaki obey hadass
ahran yarn gomez Emily Holland Norah
Keller Tamar MIT Lauren young receiving
the doctoral degree in psychology
Rebecca Martin chef Kalman Sudi made
[Applause]
Raymond crooks
Matthew Bailey receiving the doctoral
degree in religion Laura makai receiving
a doctoral degree in Slavic languages
Michael M ass organ 8 drill reef
[Applause]
receiving a doctoral degree in social
work
Angela ephah Suzanne been receiving the
doctoral degree in sociology Jinping Lee
receiving a doctoral degree in socio
medical sciences Jose Diaz Jr I'll see
ya Anderson Matthew Kelly receiving the
doctoral degree in statistics young boom
TRO Richard Nyberg you King MA
[Applause]
you engine gal receiving a doctoral
degree in sustainable development
Kimberly or Remus Stephanie Lackner
Stephan Mirta a all Frank
[Applause]
receiving a doctoral degree in
anthropology and education in Teachers
College Megan should see receiving the
doctor degree in economics and education
from Teachers College
Elizabeth Copco receiving the doctoral
degree in applied anthropology from
Teachers College Bryan O'Hare receiving
the doctoral degree in applied
behavioral analysis from Teachers
College
Vanessa Loren profet Michele Mackay
[Applause]
Kelly Mercola receiving a doctoral
degree in applied behavioral analysis
from Teachers College Frank free us
jasira Farrell receiving the doctoral
degree in cognitive studies in education
from Teachers College yuan wang
receiving a doctoral degree in
behavioral nutrition from Teachers
College genera Tate receiving the
doctoral degree in cognitive science
from Teachers College Sarich Eichorn
Qasim receiving the doctoral degree in
comparative and international education
from Teachers College Victor Janka
receiving the doctoral degree in
mathematics education from Teachers
College Laura gonna be receiving the
doctoral degree in theatre no Amy on di
receiving the doctoral degree in
political science
Lee IU
[Applause]
and now my parting remarks to the
graduating classes during your stay in
this institution we have endeavored to
train you how to think write and speak
like a member of an academic field as a
participant in an intellectual community
defined by the mores and convention of
your discipline leaving in the process
little time or room for much else indeed
looking back at the foundational myth of
the more than modern university one can
detect readily a desire to place the
institution in and location of exception
with respect to the social as an
enterprise that arises force and reason
for being from its insularity from its
distance from societal concerns this is
part and parcel of the apprenticeship
model of graduate education and explains
to a large degree the sense of
loneliness that we all have felt at one
time or another while in graduate school
as if we all had to recreate for
ourselves and within ourselves the
principal tenets of our chosen
discipline and thus engage in a project
of intellectual self fashioning that
necessarily has to keep the world at bay
given the effort the long effort that
you have expended in achieving this goal
you would be justified in thinking that
the triumph that you celebrate today
surely should be enough and yet the
Spanish philosopher Jose Ortega y Gasset
wrote in the early 20th century an
aphorism that comes to mind to describe
what I'm hoping to convey to you as you
lead this institution Joe Sergio Amit
second stanza is Enola salvo age'
Nomi salvo Joe which can be loosely
translated as I am myself and my
circumstance and if I do not redeem it I
cannot redeem myself
since November of last year most
academic institutions in the nation have
been buffeted by the unexpected outcome
of a general election whose principal
ideological contours appeared to issue
from a version of this country that is
felt by some of us to be unsettling and
unfamiliar I do not want to challenge or
bemoan the results of that election here
but to invoke it as an object lesson for
all of us using the very analytical
tools that you have learned at Columbia
and which we live by we should endeavor
to understand the phenomenon down to its
root causes but perhaps more important
it is for us to be chastened by the very
surprise with which we received this
event for in hindsight now all of the
pieces were readily available to us that
would have allowed us to almost predict
as opposed to being surprised by the
results of the last election the
indifference at the radical
concentration of wealth and resulting
income inequality the disregard for a
lowered standard of living for many of
our middle class citizens the shrugging
of shoulders at the seemingly ones on
police killings of black citizens the
lack of concern with a pollution of the
public's fear with misinformation the
conundrum that on the one hand our
current economic system has ushered in
the wondrous wondrous world in which we
live but that it also has a continual
propensity to naturalize inequalities
and to produce narratives of success
about individual effort that justify
those inequalities all of these
circumstances point to the loss of our
sense of the Commons of the beliefs that
we have some responsibility to our
brethren and that our fundamental
assumption should be
what is best is what is good for the
largest number of people have we allowed
ourselves to see the phenomena we would
not have been staggered by the events of
November
the university may have been created to
keep the world at bay outside its walls
but we should not allow that
mythological foundation to determine our
relationship with our surroundings the
very distilled concentration the
monomaniacal attention to your
intellectual projects that has allowed
you to be where you are today is a
decided strength but it can also lead
imperceptibly to a withdrawal from the
world that is not that different and it
effects from outright neglect struggling
against the insular experience in which
you have to invert yourself to be
successful in graduate school will
perhaps be the most taxing the most
demanding task you will undertake in the
next chapter of your life everything
that you have learned the Columbia will
only acquire its full significance when
you're able to articulate its meaning
for the Commons
hence in spite of the requisite headlong
plunge into our disciplinary Miglia we
must never lose sight of the larger
social context that will endow our work
with its ultimate significance we are as
a society at Pearl of losing that sense
of responsibility toward the common good
without which our work will be
diminished but more important without
which no understanding or application of
justice may sustain itself your studies
have endowed you with powerful
analytical tools and equally effective
powers of persuasion and you should use
them to protect the health of the social
compact to strengthen the resilience of
our common bonds strive to be happy as
an individual
but always keep in mind Ortega's
admonition that if you do not also
endeavour to redeem your circumstance
your own fulfillment will be in jeopardy
never lose sight of the fact that many
persons even absolute strangers have
contributed to this personal success of
yours that we celebrate today and that
the best way to acknowledge that debt is
through your renewed commitment to the
essential business of being human among
and alongside other human beings we
arrive then at the end of this
magnificent ceremony go forth to be our
representatives and emissaries to the
world and all of us at Columbia will
rejoice in your inevitable achievements
make us and your relatives and friends
prouder still about you than we are
today will the candidates please stand
so we may give them a final round of
applause
[Music]
you're all invited to champagne
reception immediately following the
ceremony at Avery Plaza under the tent
I asked friends and families to wait
until after the faculty and the
candidates have ascended the low library
steps before exiting
you
[Music]